[Music]
you guys you never know who's gonna
change your life you know and for me it
was a TSA agent I met recently I was
going through airport security and
something in my head touched off the
machine and this black woman with
beautiful hair said mmm okay I'm gonna
have to Pat you down right now now I
know you're getting nervous because the
white girl is doing a black person voice
and you think it's racist but let me
explain something to you guys sometimes
black people sound like this hello I'd
like some tea sometimes black people
sound like this hi I'm John I'm here to
sell you a mortgage sometimes white
people sound like this cuz that's a
black baby now this woman just happened
to sound like this and so I'm like why
are they patting my head whoa what
happened and then I remembered oh these
are hair extensions so I said my hair is
fake it's sewn into my head I don't have
drugs smuggled in my head and she went
get over here right now why you white
girls I was coming in here screaming
it's my hair extensions I know it's your
weave now I didn't even know as a white
person I was allowed to call it a weave
it was so freeing when she said that to
me she said when black women come in we
look at each other we know what's going
on okay now did you get that hair
extension so it would look fake cuz it
looked good let me tell you something
your weave your business no one had ever
given me advice like that not even my
parents have talked to me that way when
I look back on it I feel like I was
raised by wolves you know and before I
left she said let me just tell you one
more thing that weave is between you and
God I was like oh my god so I would love
that definitive proof that there's a God
you know the atheist and the religious
people are wrong there is a God but he
is just making sure that women's hair
extensions look real
and people are praying to him and he's
overwhelmed I can't stop the war
I just am here to tell women your weave
your business so I was on this show two
years ago telling jokes about how I was
just married and that's really really
good to be back and I'm divorced now
though don't know don't be sad divorce
is just a legal term for no man has
farted in my bed for two years but
actually I went on a date right after I
got divorced I was like I'm gonna be a
cougar now you know and I went out with
I was 36 at the time I went with a 21
year old I will never do that again I
had to pick him up at the gas station
because it scarred Grenada gas because
his bank had run out of money and I took
him back to my place and I offered him
some wine and he said when did you get
the wine and I didn't understand that
question
I was thinking does he mean what vintage
year is this wife and he said no no we
didn't stop at a 7-eleven on the way
home when did you get the wine and I was
like Oh sweetie when you're a grown-up
you can just have wine waiting at the
house sometimes you're so old and tired
you didn't even want to drink it
so it didn't work out between us cuz he
was really cute and in a band and he had
a lot of girlfriends I found out on
Facebook I didn't have the internet when
I was his age and I really resent that
you know when I was his age it was a lot
of work to find out if someone was
cheating on you you had to get dressed
get drunk go to a party and scream in
his face are you screwing other girls
respect your elders people but here's
the thing married people are the worst
people in the world now don't get
offended I know you're like but I give
to cats without whiskers every month Jen
individually you're probably good people
but as a unit you're awful and I'm gonna
apologize to all the single people here
for how us married people treated you
you know what we did married people we
went on a honeymoon with our spouses we
took pictures by the beach did we put
those in a photo album because it's no
one's business but our own no we turned
it into a Christmas card and we sent it
to all you single people during the
loneliest most suicidal time of year
you're sitting on your couch thinking
maybe this is the year that someone will
love me you spill some eggnog on your
cat's fur you lick it off no one's there
to see it who cares
all my friends now are married with kids
that's all I hang out with and I was at
my friend's house the other night and
they were putting their toddler to bed
and he was crying I don't want to go to
bed at 7:30 p.m. and when I saw that I
felt like crying because I was like I
would love to go to bed at 7:30 p.m. and
have it be socially acceptable and not
have people go Jen
are you depressed why are you in bed get
out there you're divorced now I have
another friend who takes this class and
they say don't pick up your toddler when
he's crying in the crib and I kind of
judge her for that you know she's trying
to teach him independence I'm like he 0
years old he's not gonna remember this
lesson you know you don't need a class
my theory is as long as you don't set
your kid on fire he'll be fine but
here's the thing if I did have a kid I
would totally pick him up if he was
crying and I would put him in a car and
I would drive him to a corner and I
would say you cry there but I'm not a
monster
I would circle back around the block and
if he's still there I would take him
home because it would be meant to be
thank you
[Applause]
you